boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakhyan we
are at the transformative technologies
conference and holy cow we are learning
about amazing people amazing companies
we are now sitting down with dr pablo
paredes hello hey nice to meet you thank
you for coming on to the show my
pleasure i really appreciate it thank
you
an instructor in radiology yep
zeitgeist psychiatry and population
health and population health at stanford
university wow okay radiology psychiatry
and population health this is going to
be such a cool conversation i'm really
looking forward to it okay so maybe
before we get to the
thesis and cores of your work sure tell
us about your life you know who are you
how did you get to yeah yeah where i am
yeah well i'm gonna try to make a long
story short um
the reason i'm here i would say is
because i actually like you know have a
family member who suffers from a mental
disorder and it took a long time in
south america to find
some kind of like relief um
decades uh and um at one point in my
whole like uh history of like dealing
with this thing i
was able to discover cognitive
behavioral therapy and a bunch of other
like very like you know empirically
driven uh techniques that helped
relieve some of the problems but never
solved them and uh ever since i've been
like trying to understand how can i do
something as an engineer to solve this
problem what was the ailment
oh obsessive compulsive disorder yeah so
at the end of the day the idea is to you
know find the right this uh diagnostics
and provide the right treatment at the
time
making the long story short in part also
because i had to like you know i had i
was an entrepreneur and ecuador sadly
tanked in the 2000 i had to like get out
of there i studied with a fulbright
scholarship at georgia tech and then i
had to go back i worked in ecuador and
brazil but at one point i decided you
know what i'm spending all my free time
researching this topic of like mental
health like literally and my own money
on top of my career which i was doing
really good and i really enjoyed as
business
manager but i decided to become a
scientist so i just quit and i came to
berkeley i did my phd in computer
science and
i focused on mental health technology
from day one
um
now i'm more into the world of what's
called precision health so i did a
postdoc here at stanford and the people
from the mets in computer science but
the people in the med school are
creating a new center that's called the
precision health and integrated
diagnostics and precision health is not
precision medicine i want to make sure
that that's understood precision
medicine is how do i measure exactly
what's going on on you to
solve some problems precision health how
do i measure you being healthy and keep
you that way
so medicine is to fix and health is to
to keep you going strong okay and that's
what i want to do so i don't i i'm still
focused on mental health but i what i
want is people to never fall sick yeah
yes
so
to get rid of the pathologies even
before they start and to be predictive
and
predictive and proactive
yes yes now what how did the story with
your family member where did where did
that go because we just yeah we just had
bashar on this show okay and bashar was
saying that he has uh in his in his uh
neuroscience lab that they have magnetic
it's getting much better yeah
it's getting better i think we're
getting close to much better treatment
and i hope it will be like uh
sooner rather than later that we find a
better treatment
right now it's just more of the same in
south america we have a different uh you
know
level of advancement but i'm very i'm
paying a lot of attention to tms and
also to ketamine research that other
researchers are doing too both both are
very interesting yes yes
now okay
so um radiology psychiatry and public
health right so now as you as you finish
uh
yeah you were doing it was it was post
post doc yeah at stanford right as
you're finishing up how did yeah how did
you decide to do instructing and also
right so so i mean in reality i i do
research the instructor is just a label
for you know a
very junior faculty level so i have my
own lab i got like a small startup
package to work on it and i have
students working with me and even a
postdoc working with me and the whole
purpose is to like work in this core
problem of like how do we keep you
healthy for as long as possible so i'm
fascinated with the questions around
how do we use interaction between the
environment
and the individual because i am actually
a human computer interaction
researcher
so what i want to do is how do we
transform the
wild the new wild into like something
that can help and by by the new wild i
mean
buildings like 90 of us spend
um i'm sorry we spent 90 percent of our
time in buildings uh when we're all
awake when we're aware yeah and sleeping
both like you know oh yeah
yeah
so both we spend like too much time too
much time in buildings yeah or i don't
know if it's too much time you know i
used to think that it was too much time
i i just dropped it too much and i'm
like well that's what it is that's what
it is that's why this is our new
environment
even though there's so much pointing
towards
forest bathing and nature oh there's
many positive aspects of going outdoors
and people should do that and we could
keep trying to recover that lost terrain
but 90 is a sizable number we spend a
lot of time indoors and i think we
should
take that and instead of fighting it
like okay how do we transform the
environment
such that it really can benefit our mind
and our body and this speaks about like
the transition from the cubicle right to
the transition to these openers yeah
well there's many variations i think we
still need to do a lot of like more
hardcore research
on the way that we design furniture the
way that we design
peripherals the way that we design
architecture the way that we design even
like materials and floors and things in
order to like not only measure variables
like you know productivity and comfort i
think those are not enough we should be
measuring
variables of well-being as well
interesting no okay you just list so
many variables you're making my mind go
everywhere i love it so okay let's take
an example yeah so
when you want to
when you see a sp like a building how do
you architect a building to optimize for
well-being yeah
well right now we actually have a very
interesting i'm part of a project with
professor james landay from cs and
professor sarah um
blingtong from the civil engineering
department and we're discussing what
does that mean
how do you architect do we have to look
at the windows how the windows let
propagate light from outdoors do we have
to look at the
temperature because now we basically
have all fake temperature everywhere
do we have to look at perhaps
the type of like emblems and colors that
surrounds us so that produce you know
some kind of meaning
do we have to look maybe at other
variables that have to do with the
materials and how they how toxic they
are or not toxic
at the end of the day i think the the
truth is that we don't really know
enough i think architecture has
a tradition of like uh focus on
aesthetics and beauty and that's already
a very good principle to like do
something that's meaningful but it's not
enough i think there's not enough core
science to understand well if i change
the window size or the openings or
whatever how much does that affect the
amount of stress that i have how much
does this affect we haven't measured it
and that's exactly what we're doing
right now we're trying to measure
trying to understand
in my lab i'm more focused on the
furniture itself on the furniture yeah
i'm very interested in
furniture that
you seen that
crazy desk that some silicon valley
companies making where you it's like a
dent it's like you're at a dentist's
office and you go like you go back and
you can work like that yeah no i mean
i've seen very creative things and i
think we have to keep producing new
stuff i think that's very cool
i've been looking a lot at the
traditional seed stand desk lately
like studying it and it turns out that
you know most of the
new deployments that you see out there
of new offices
brings with them like this seed stand
desks with the hope that people will be
like more like you know active and that
those are the desks the ones that you
press about to go up and down some are
more or less fancy than that but
essentially the same thing
sadly you know the the literature shows
that 70 of those desks after three
months remain sitting nobody
uses them anymore they don't go stand
they don't go between they don't use
them anymore
people don't press the button anymore
yeah they just sit it just sits oh
interesting so it's not
broken three months people stop stop
doing it interesting and then you ask
there's an other studies that say like
you they had other researchers ask like
why and essentially is apathy it's
empathy yeah essentially interesting
essentially so we're actually designing
a what if the desk
move i mean yeah that's exactly what
we're doing we just created a desk that
we call the haunted desk it moves on its
own
if you are apathetic about it then the
freaking thing is going to move up and
down yeah yeah yeah you shouldn't be
bothered and we're running you know
science behind that you know how do
people do it so far what we've noticed
is that people too it's kind of funny
you actually see the person typing and
then this stuff's going up and they keep
going with it
and they keep working and most of the
time they don't complain there's some
glitches here and there and there's like
more research to be done but in general
sure yeah why not that's so cool so yeah
i'm very interested for example in desks
that move i'm very interested in chairs
i'm like can i make the chair
uncomfortable
uncomfortable after a while so you are
like sitting there and after a while the
chair starts like tweaking a little bit
and then you feel like compelled to like
oh to move your body yeah oh interesting
just a tiny baby so the uncomfortability
will trigger movement yeah
because otherwise the comfortability
will trigger seat
sitting forever yes
i think we have to fight comfort
that is interesting
i like the way you think that's a very
like contrary yeah and you know i mean
yeah maybe it's my real nature but are
you are you do you like decrease one of
the sides of the chairs yeah yeah we
have actually a chair with four
actuators in the legs we can do anything
we want
we are very interested in a chair that
stinks a sinking chain yeah so after a
while it starts thinking unless you take
a break yeah
oh that's interesting so there is a
little bit of like you know artistic
exploration but also some like
hard-rooted questions of behavior change
like if you look at the literature
behavior change for a long time we have
been pounding on the possibility of like
convincing people persuading people to
do things
and we're just not doing a great job
so i think we need to continue on that
path and maybe look deeper maybe
mindsets you know there's some research
about that from ali crown very
interesting
but i think we should also just get
things moving and like force you to do
like you go to the restaurant and your
chair's gone
yeah
what happens what happens then the then
uh then you stand and work maybe or
maybe you go for a walk maybe yeah i
mean see obviously we are not going to
go to the point that's going to hurt cr
uh you know creativity or productivity
or like
but i think people can tolerate these
like changes in the environment it's
also a little bit of a surprise
yeah it's really fun that you know your
chair is making a joke like that like
where did you go where'd you go and the
chair might be hiding behind it or like
like peeping yeah exactly i don't know i
think i think it sounds silly and i
think we should explore some silliness
but there is a little bit of value on
like this exploration of the environment
forcing you
as a forcing function for you to do
things i agree yeah yeah yeah so now
keep going in the in the you know you're
talking about furniture yes yes chairs
um what else but also you know you're
also mentioning some interesting things
like oh if the chair was on wheels and
had some motors yeah and also had a
camera on it right well it could just
move whenever you're not on yeah and
then you could be like damn it yeah yeah
yeah at least interesting silly yeah or
maybe it moves closer to the window so
you can read with natural light as
opposed to the the thing it basically
says come sit here here right exactly i
mean i think there's many possibilities
and i think there's many things that we
can like look into like you know we have
already
chairs and desks and things we have also
peripherals like the display display
the keyboard the mouse these are very
interesting devices
they have actually much more power than
it looks like yeah i'm actually very
interested in like can i detect stress
just by the way you use them and i've
been able to publish a paper on the move
movement of the mouse oh i was i was i
was just about to say there's you can
for sure detect stress by how hard
someone should when when you know oh
yeah
and then someone's like oh i wish this
was working you can
click it multiple times oh yeah really
hard yeah yeah we actually have a paper
on that with a colleague javier
hernandez we did that the problem is
that normal five dollar keyboards and
five dollar mouse don't have pressure
sensors
but you i don't need them i can actually
detect by the way you move the mouse
interesting because when you get
stressed your muscles get tense yeah
yeah and when they get tense
the way that you handle things changes
the trajectory
changes so you do exactly the same thing
that you were doing under calm and under
stress and you see a slight change in
the trajectory and you can do math with
that does that mean
i'm moving
less calm i'm a little like faster no
that's the beauty it's not about the
speed it's about the shape the precision
the shape of you landing
into that area oh interesting so maybe
if i'm
if i'm calmer i'm moving it directly to
the point but if i'm agitated i might
shoot over
that it's actually no it's actually you
become more precise with the stress
actually you can be very very precise
that's why stress is not necessarily a
bad thing interesting it's actually
something that's necessary you become a
bit more precise if you get too stressed
then you start making mistakes okay okay
but if you get the right amount of
stress you become a bit more precise
actually more efficient so then yeah
tell me more about it so we use the
movement of the mouse to basically
detect stress chest by the way you move
by creating a model of the arm a mass
spring damper model of the arm so that's
like a robotic model instead of doing
machine learning trying to infer things
we literally propose that you know if i
can look at the data
from the movement i can create some
equations to model what will be a
resonating
uh an oscillator
so an oscillator has a spring and a mass
so we modeled that from the arm and we
said like the muscles are like springs
they basically contract and it's like
when they get tense they basically are
resonating at a different uh frequency
and we proved that mathematically
oh
so we were able to show that basically
with movement i can infer the amount of
stiffness in there yeah oh cool yeah and
we actually validated that also in the
car that's another space i'm very
interested in the car okay i've been
doing a lot of research in the car we
actually extended this idea of movement
and we did it with a steering wheel so
we basically got too stressed under
you know and then come and drive
everything else kept equal we shown that
you know with stress the way you take
the turns is again a little bit more
precise and that's basically expressed
in a muscle spring damper and you can
show the the coefficient of like
rigidity
and you can basically infer the amount
of stiffness due to stress
in the arm
yeah as driving or also or on a mouse
yeah so i'm very interested like you
know in the car you have more sensors
you have the steering wheel
you have this beautiful sensor for the
for the legs you have your body against
another potential sensor of posture and
all that so you can get a lot of pretty
cool information from a car and to be
very honest i'm not
it's not a car that fascinates me it's
the commute that fascinates me yes the
commute is amazingly interesting it's
this moment in the day
when you're moving from a high
productivity environment to a
very much like relaxation environment
yeah and you should go with that flow
you should go there and basically feel
better but many many people don't happen
to have that luxury they go from stress
to more stress
and they fight their way through to try
to sleep and they have poor quality
sleep and the commute is not helping
much the commute is basically just this
link between these two places without
adding value and many times actually
exacerbating yeah because of all the
factors of like driving
and basically what i think is that that
moment can be used to like can we we can
repurpose the commute
from a bug into a feature yeah and the
reason i'm all interested in the
computer is not just because of that
situation it's because it is the right
moment to do it it's the moment when
you're moving from this environment to
environment this is an important moment
in the day you want to make sure that
the the mood the well-being the health
is high when they're in this commuting
time correct and they i want that by the
time they have done commuting they are
in the right state of mind they should
be much calmer if they're going home and
they should be much alert much more
alert if they're coming from home to
work work yeah interesting yeah such
that you know you deliver the person in
the right state state of mind
interesting and then the other thing
also about the commute that's very
interesting is that you know it happens
twice a day yes
every day
for 50 million americans they spend
about an hour
so there's a lot of people doing this
thing yeah and i used to tell this to my
colleague psychiatrist i'm like you know
you you know playing the jokes about the
sofas you know we always refer to the
psychiatrist like the sofa that you
really want is the sofa in the car
because now you have the person trapped
they get in the car and they move they
cannot even get out of this place so the
place where you can really intervene is
in the car while you're commuting you
have them captive they're captive in the
car yeah and it happens twice a day yeah
what would be the variables that you
would tweak yeah on the way to work on
the way yeah so we we are actually
already publishing papers on that it's
i'm very interested with breathing rates
breathing that's the first one yeah
there's many aspects to breathing and in
this conference especially there's a lot
of people thinking very carefully about
breathing yes
i'm very interested in the chest
getting people to breathe slowly
like you know for most people doing
diaphragmatic these complicated
advanced techniques it's just difficult
to to acquire
breathing slowly everybody can
now sustaining the slow breath is a bit
more difficult so we created a chair
that has like imagine a bunch of like a
massage
a haptic massage interaction in the back
is a bunch of models that basically
give you a signal that goes up
and then it goes down
and that sequence is linked to your
breathing rate
so essentially it asks you to follow the
sequence for you to like start breathing
at the same pace and then we reduce the
speed of the breathing and then people
start breathing slowly we reduce it by
30 percent
and not only that the beauty is that
during that time we measure all the
performance indicators like you know
lane keeping and like heartbreaking and
there weren't the major distortions
anything that would have affected safety
so you can
do the same thing you're doing
but less stress
because you because you're breathing
breathing slower
and you're helping them breathe slower
on the way back home through a through
the back the back of the chair has yeah
these actuators that gives yeah and that
it rises up exactly and then it and then
it goes down yeah
interesting so then you you now you
follow your breath to that physically
you follow the breath basically and
there's many good properties of putting
it on the on the back the main one is
that people basically say it's less kind
of demanding that anything
people tried it with lights with voices
like not just with this simple massage
in the back it works yes and then the
other thing that they like a lot about
the interaction was that they actually
can drive and if they want to do a
maneuver of some sort at some point they
can always disengage just like a little
bit a little bit do the thing and then
like go back in yeah that's interesting
yeah what about on the way to work yeah
that that's the other question like what
are we doing the way to work i would say
i've been focusing more on the winding
down part right now but there's the way
to work and i think at increasing
attention and focus maybe like the smell
of coffee smell would be very
interesting i'm actually talking to a
startup around here that has this like
more dry method of generating smells on
demand and we're very interested in
using something like that to generate
alertness i think breathing also can be
used but in this case it will be
breathing faster
so if i get you to breathe slightly
faster interesting i can actually get
you more aroused it works both ways and
we actually have a small paper
where we investigated can we use fast
breathing fast-paced breathing
for um fatigue
you know again it was more at the end of
the day
but i think in the morning similar
you're like still a bit drowsy waking up
breathe a bit faster
yeah
posture will also help posture like yeah
the right posture in the seat totally
yeah yeah if you maybe you can
incorporate yeah that would move your
shoulders back that'd really make you
feel better so we're actually working uh
talking to a very um
interesting company that built
you know car car seat makers the
companies that make car seats are
actually pretty big companies that's
amazing like billion multi-billion
multi-billion dollars because they make
hundreds of millions of yeah and the
seed is a very important piece of the
car very important yes yes so they uh
they're very they they are very
interesting blending
the three things that we just discussed
some posture
some potential guided breathing and
maybe some scent
as well interesting yeah to get
basically the
the engagement to be not just the level
of arousal but also a little bit of like
have the pleasant feeling which
basically puts you in a good mood
wow yeah
so 50 million in just the u.s community
yeah a day a day and and that that and
that's huge like you said you're you're
you're trapped in the car yeah you are
literally trapped
so there's so much you can do to make
them to do the preparation yeah for work
yeah better yeah the preparation for
home
as well because i also remember i wanted
to mention this when you come home yeah
a lot of your uh happiness when you come
home
is in your family at least if you're
with a family is based on the way you
first treat your significant other when
you come home so if you have an elevated
mood when you come home and you and you
give that loving energy to your spouse
it changes the rest of the evening
yeah completely agree
that's why i think the delivering of the
individual at the end of the trajectory
of the commute
is extremely valuable
because i agree with you it's the first
interactions that happen at home and at
work
that set the tone of the whole
experience yeah
so if we can make that the first
impression
better even though it's a repeated
impression every day but the first
interaction better
i completely agree with you it will have
a difference and not only that there's
some signs that show that but yeah yeah
if there's like a couple of exchange of
like a loving exchange or like smile at
least yes the whole the rest of the
evening flows yes maybe you come like oh
my god you know this day and like what
did you do i have no time right now the
whole evening at least a little like
at least a little like i love you i had
a complicated video exactly but at least
i'm happy to see you yeah yeah it helps
i mean people will say well you can do
you can train yourself to do that and
then it comes a diff a third concept
that i'm very interested in recent
actually talking to nicole here that
made me realize there's this we in
science we talk a lot about sensors and
interventions right we send something
and then we do something about it
intervention
there is the for me this
pre-intervention phase
you prepare the person
to have an intervention so let's say the
intervention is right this loving
conversation
which is actually well documented called
the construct active constructive
talking
if you're not in the right mood
i will
kind of give you a low probability of
you engaging in active constructive
totally so i might not necessarily need
to like
change the dynamic completely by by
getting you in the best mood i just
prepare you such that you adhere to the
other intervention which is the
conversational active conversation so i
use the commute as a preparation exactly
for a more profound intervention yes yes
happening at home and so now where i
like how you're
how you're making this
sit because you're making it sit with
the you have a huge intention so even
before the intervention you have the
intention to prepare the person for it
correct so then where else can this be
used i mean the commute's a good one
home commute works a good one i mean
this can be used in preparation for so
much like so much i think we should be
researching very actively in this topic
for example one anecdotal experience i
had no no no scientific anecdotal is i'm
a
quite explosive like you know passionate
individual as you might maybe infer and
i used to work in business and i used to
have these issues i used to work in
marketing in the ninth floor and
engineering was on the second floor of
this building in ecuador and sometimes
they really did something that like
upset me greatly i used to take the
elevator come out shouting like how do
you dare to have done this to this
client
it's just you know very bad then i
realized that you know instead of taking
the elevator i should take the stairs
so now i have seven steps seven floors
and i did it a bit faster
so i did exert
i
went to the same place it took me one
more minute
but my mood was different when i arrived
there i wasn't i was still sharp ready
to say what i wanted to say but not with
the same bitterness that i did with the
other one that for example these
transitions for you to like go and
communicate with people i think you
should use those transitions yeah
to prepare yourself to engage in a more
active even if it's like a more
difficult conversation you can prepare
to that by exerting a little bit by
maybe taking a longer route by chest
like you know maybe taking a coffee like
don't just go
yeah there's there's something
i think
with especially you know the work that
i've done now with tony robbins with
with priming um and there's a lot of
programming yeah yeah there's a lot of
other uh wellness coaches and languages
that help with this essence of priming
yeah it's just that you know you're
priving for priming for your uh for a
deep conversation with your partner well
get into your heart and give the love
give the love yes if when i was going to
give the tedx talking on in october and
san francisco i was like yes
i was getting super ready and i was also
grounding
yeah and so that that really got me into
into the into the stage
for me so there's so what i love i love
the idea of priming and and preparing
for that intervention yeah that's so
cool systemically right
systemically that that's the part where
i think we need science like how do we
really measure
the outcome such that i know that you're
ready to take the intervention and use
it and adhere and adopt it
otherwise it's just random search we
could use like machine learning random
search and maybe that's a good way to
start you know like just testing what
happens but systemically ask the
question can we create experiences that
are conducive to more adherence and
adoption of an intervention can we do it
and what does that mean yes yes
and
and i would be very interested to just
know which which ones would you want
like which interventions would you find
to be the first ones that you would want
to start studying right
well i mean i i'm pretty having a lot of
fun right now with the car and furniture
i think uh behaviors that have to do
with mobility mobility mobility is
extremely interesting i'm fascinated
with many effects many things that have
to do with mobility first of all
i think the body is the ultimate like
stimulation
uh system for the brain
brains are connected to bodies we sense
we have multiple connections i think we
should as much as we progress on the
part of like meditation
we should progress in the art of like
using your body
oh my gosh you know ido portal
um
he taught me about the uh he showed me
how you know the reptile move is on the
ground and stuff and how humans if we i
started crawling basically right on the
ground to test it out yeah very
literally started like circling around
on the ground on all fours yeah yeah and
it oh i hear my hips go
you know yeah oh opens up my whole body
yeah it feels amazing yeah i know i
think movement is fascinating like
there's so many things about movement
like you know
the problem is that we we we tend to go
to streams all the time that's why i in
my talk i was talking about saddle
interventions i want subtle movement
shadow
but constantly assessing it and
constantly encouraging it
like you know we think we're too binary
we're like go from sitting to running
and everything in between seems like not
count almost like it's not true and now
we know better there's better signs that
shows like
are they how do they say the best state
is the next one right it's always keep
it moving
so you know subtle movement for example
can we do something just by stretching
like stretching is where we can we get
the chair to guide you to stretch yeah
breathing is also a movement can we for
example use rocking rocking is a very
nice
way of you sit on a rocking chair and
you feel kind of like relaxed oh yeah
like can we induce that in a in a car in
a office chair can we make it a tracking
officer why not we used to have so many
more rocking chairs when our with our
grandparents yeah i know where are the
rocking chairs because we have no time
to see the name so okay so again so now
let's put them in the office then let's
try it
and you know it's actually interesting
because we actually with the chair that
i mentioned that we built we have been
exploring actually not just
the opportunity of relaxation but
actually the opportunity to
engage in more like attention and focus
and
again we don't have uh scientific
findings yet but we have tested this
with several people we have a chair that
moves
that literally moves from side to side
programmatically
and those who actually describe
themselves are very fidgety
they love this chair
like me i sit on that and the chair is
shaking me and i am actually able to
like do stuff and well it actually
focuses me kind of like relaxes
it no it's like flashes might need to
move yeah now those who are very stable
naturally they they don't like it
there's like no keep my chair stable
don't shake it and so i think it's not
for everybody but for example movement
might be very useful for some people and
i've been researching about this and
there's actually some kindergartens that
they are using these unstable stools
for adhd kids yeah you you keep them
balanced balls or balance balls or other
tools that look kind of like a cone
yeah those are good i love some when
you're when you're when you were talking
about having very slight movements from
side to side while working for me that
sounds exciting it's very cool yeah it's
very cool super good the other the other
part of the body that you know
i'm interesting is the whole
proprioception and the whole like you
know you're burning calories when you're
doing this oh yeah yeah very cool yeah i
mean i'm moving my yeah my shoulders my
triceps my body
it's all in my lower back let's say i
get you moving you know
one or two hours out of the eight that
you're just sitting there you will burn
something you burn something but then
day
yeah
i bet we wouldn't be as stiff yeah
that's fair and the other thing also is
like again it's about preparation if
you've been a bit more active during the
day the possibility of you engaging in
more
executive activities like more more
exercise than it's i think it should go
up
because you're not going from like
potato culture straight to right exactly
you're level up from there up a little
bit yeah and you're like i feel loose i
want to go do something
right interesting yeah yeah this is so
cool you know what i'm envisioning
i'm envisioning you know the i'm
envisioning these very futuristic
furnitures i'm envisioning like me going
to the bathroom and then the chair being
by the window when i come back and i'm
like yeah yeah okay i'll move my i'll go
over there
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah the commute in the car to like
you know really like increase my breath
all the way home and and uh get me more
prepared for a loving engagement on my
way home you know i love how you think
about all this it's very very
important and futuristic and
and we have we actually there's a lot of
people that like um
at like cca the california college of
arts up in san francisco very much make
all of this i know i know there are some
people actually one of my co-advisers in
my postdoc was wendy joo professor who
now is in cornell tech she has these
beautiful ideas around like robotics
i just the best robots i've seen have
come from her head i think you know she
changed because all these robots that
look like humans and anthropomorphic
those are a fantasy of you know us as
humans to
project ourselves she's like we have to
like get make an ottoman that's a robot
so you're like sitting there and the
ottoman comes and like offers
himself or herself to basically give you
relief so she's coming you raise your
things and the ottoman goes in
oh that's a cool robot because that all
that that decompresses your back yeah
that's a cool robot you know yeah or
like she also has these others the um
the garage
cans the the garbage can oh it comes to
you it not only comes to you comes to
you and shakes it like like a like a dog
shakes it and you're like oh yeah you
throw the trash
that's great that's the type of dramas i
find we should be thinking more of
in general i like yeah this type of this
type of robotics i think but we really
need to invest more as opposed to like
just trying to replicate ourselves yeah
i think we should like play with the
things that are around us yeah maybe the
maybe the light is uh is decreasing in
the room that you're in so maybe the
light comes on in the room maybe
yeah lights were also very interested i
mean we haven't uh done a lot but lights
are very the other concept that i'm very
interested interested so complementary
to the the desk is what i call
non-volitional intervention so i'm
forcing you to do things like literally
by reconfiguring the environment i'm
forcing you yeah to adopt a different
behavior would you call it a
non-volitional non-volitional yeah yeah
interesting so you don't do it with your
own volition no you you are forced to do
it cool okay whatever that means in
terms of i'm not gonna get in there like
ethics or that that's another
conversation that's a different
conversation but and if it's better for
your health if it's yeah i think i think
we should explore it yeah and the other
one is subliminal
how do i get you to change certain
aspects of your life without you even
perceiving it
like literally without even perceiving
it interesting
so i'm very interested right now i'm
working with a display
that actually generates a signal changes
the hue of the display yeah not the
brightness the hue
in a very subtle way
such that you may not even perceive it
yeah because it's actually working
operating in one part of your visual
perception that's very like
linear very almost like saturated so
your visual cortex perceives the changes
but you don't so you're typing an email
you see the same thing but your the
background of the of the email is
changing and we generate the right
frequency to induce certain changes in
your brain like gamma entrainment
exactly or like delta so we can generate
the frequencies with a display
the same display that you use to write
the email
now we'll i mean just to just to explore
that for a moment if i'm looking at the
display and the display is the leds are
what what are what are you doing with
the leds because is it like a yeah is it
like a couple milliseconds is doing
something very short very short so to
the point where it doesn't even look
like i'm yeah seeing a change in the
screen correct
interesting yeah and then that can
potentially entrain ace potentially
there's there's there's uh empirical
evidence that we need but yeah
could increase flow states and stuff
potentially
wow this is so cool i'm really happy
that you're doing everything that you're
exploring you're like you're like a cr
how can i explain you you're like a
uh
you're
you're what would be the following word
a creep
maybe like a creative environments
designer something like that yeah
environments designers something like
that yeah creative creative healthy
environments healthy environments yeah
yeah healthy environments i want to
create an ecology of like i think i
think our environment should have we
should give more life to our things
uh you know we talk about ecologies
outside
we don't have an ecology anymore because
we're actually on the top of the food
chain
so no but there's no more like
interactions with other species the
interactions are all fake and regulated
and we used to live on the prairie with
all the interactions with like bacteria
and animals now we live here here this
environment it's this yeah so our
environment should take life it should
be more like adaptive and interplaying
with you he could even play practical
jokes to you why not like like you're
coming and your chair is like hiding but
your desk is like i'm not going up yeah
yeah those are good jokes what happened
then you just laughed for a while
laughter is extremely good
for you yeah
anyways i think i think like came and
shake to them when he threw it and moved
out of the way exactly
that would be a great practical you were
like
[Laughter]
anyways i think at the end of the day i
want to bring more like dynamism to our
like a rather stale
environment the real in the wild i think
yeah yeah
i love it
what a what a pleasure this time it was
my pleasure yeah oh my gosh this has
been so enlightening um it's a very it's
so much different you're like the only
person at trans texas doing this which
that i've met so far that i really like
yeah it's very different it's very and i
love things that are very different um
from the cultural norms very copernicusy
i love it yeah yeah i'm glad i have the
opportunity to explore it yeah yeah very
happy thank you for teaching us about it
we'll have some links in the bio for you
guys to check out um also uh go thank
you for tuning in if you guys want give
us some comments below with your
thoughts let's keep making fun ideas
like this about how exactly we can
change our environments to make them
more creative more dynamic more movement
more well-being um we'd love to hear
from you also go and build the future go
manifest your dreams into the world
everyone thank you so much and we'll see
you soon
peace
very cool
thank you alan that was fun that was so
fun i love learning about you